donc voilà jason kidd heure d'arrivée
avait mis quelqu'un de dans ma bulle et
du coup on est en train de tourner
quelque chose de grave cool avec brut
[Musique]
salut à tous et jason
miller
et albert tu connais et si je te dis
mademoiselle gloria 100 le monde sait
que le fc
lorient s'est tout simplement l'une des
pionnières de youtube de sa génération
oui
[Musique]
elle a vécu des moments de pause des
voyages de groupe des rencontres ouvre
tout était faux
[Applaudissements]
mais elle a vécu aussi des moments de
galère des moments très durs
nous raconter dans fame
voilà
donc le rire raconte nous présentons un
petit et gloria alors gloria c'est une
jeune jane qui à 22 ans qui vient à
saint-etienne elle a deux petits frères
jumeaux une grande soeur et des parents
géniaux
j'ai par des lunettes
[Musique]
non en 2012 et gloria keep on peut lier
pour déménager sur saint-etienne avec sa
famille
nouvelle vie nnent nouvelle ambiance de
vos amis
la seule sous son nez
nouvelle ville nouveaux amis tous et
l'ambiance ça fait beaucoup de
nouveautés pour elle en 2012 à
saint-etienne je crois qu'elle est la
seule du tube us de la ville donc c'est
pas facile et tu imagines bien que la
cour de récré son nouveau délire d'être
sur youtube c'est pas forcément compris
et c'est le début des galères
c'était quoi ton pseudo steria sur
mademoiselle x gloria pourquoi ben je
sais pas j'étais une petite fille du
coup je me dis bon mademoiselle et
gloria pour voilà les gens sachent un
peu bas mon prénom et qu'est ce que ça a
changé dans ton quotidien l'arrivée sur
les réseaux bon bah ouais exposition
baledent dans ma vie sans rendez pas
compte parce que quand tu disais ouais
je fais des vidéos sur youtube il disait
quoi c'est quoi enfin je crois tu ta
fille gens vont être vraiment c'était
pourquoi tu ta fiche shalom attendez
vous allez voir et où enfin il se moque
un peu de moi mais gentiment tu vois ma
après il ya eu des gens qui disaient non
messine gallery and skin à et trouve
j'entendais mais j'étais leur mode vous
allez voir et bah maintenant voilà
maintenant c'est les métiers que tout le
monde veut faire donc puis un nom
[Musique]
fos ce conflit
et maria et c'était la même personne que
gloria in berck non enfin en vrai c'est
elle a commencé tout ainsi toute
commande y associant tu es tout un
sourire a explosé pas de mille questions
j'arrive à jeun j'avais 13 ans quoi 13
ans 14 enfin je faisais mes petits
montages mettait vraiment géant mode de
moi et si tu vois tu vois si tu vois pas
tant pis je pose ça je continuerai à
côté
de 12 à 17 ans et l'ascension pour
gloria et signe dans une agence avec sa
bande de potes de youtube heures il
voyage dubaï londres los angeles lui
[Musique]
franchement ça vit ça fait rêver non non
faut qu'on se dise la vérité ça vit ça
fait rêver ou quoi
jamais sorti de l'europe encore mais tu
imagines bien que sa vie que ce n'est
pas que ça retour à la réalité par mme
c'est l'année du bac et franchement
c'est pas gagné moi je suis rentré
dimanche à vue et genre l'indicé l'école
du coup quand je suis allé en costaud
mais
je voulais voir personne de mener ces
cités sur la base était monté monde et
notre bien dans la réalité
est en cours ça se passe comment à ce
moment là en cours c'est la galère pour
moi enfin je voudrais je n'arrivais pas
à suivre mais j'essaie quand même c'est
comme en ce moment là tu es entre le chu
au summum jeu cartonne sur les réseaux
et pue
c'est vrai bah en fait le parce que je
n'ai pas ces deux fois mon bac la
première année je n'ai raté de genre 0.5
du coup je voulais pas de leur passé
mais mon père il m'a dit vas-y c'est pas
grave là tu l'auras et je la repasser
ouais je l'a pas eu non tu as vécu ça
comment ben ça ça m'a fait mal en vrai
genre parce que vu que
la première fois des héros fut qu'une
ceinture a été celle de trop donner mes
cuisses à grande échelle que j'en
retiens en mode de washer céder quoi
c'est pas fait pour moi en fait jambes
du coup je voyais toutes mes copines
aussi de la vraie vie à voir leurs
badges c'est tant mieux bravo là qu'on
n'a pas la même vie et du coup je me
suis dit oui et quand on sort de toutes
sortes de duchemin scolaire parce que
j'ai le sentiment après tu as une chose
que tu en penses que quand tu réussis
pas à avoir le bac ou à l'école nappes
sont pas ma vie elle est morte on gérait
des bêtes
je mets une bombe à qui tu as
l'impression t
vraiment ce qui est costaud avec le
mental de gloria c'est que même avec 2
back raté et garde le smile ou plutôt
c'est la part entre et nous montrent sur
les réseaux comment fais tu pour garder
le sourire et la pêche au rap était déjà
prêt et boxe j'ai toujours le sourire la
pêche et où j'ai toujours un esprit on
va dire assez positif vraiment faux pas
à se compliquer dans la vie en gros à
behrami semailles même si t'es pas bien
semailles tu vas fait pareil que tu vas
bien
tu réussis pas le bac était dépité et
c'est mademoiselle gloria elles existent
sur les réseaux où elle existe mais vu
que ça ça m'avait comme affecté géant
mode et je voulais garder ça secret gens
moi je voulais pas à dire sur les
réseaux bon les gars j'ai pas eu mon bac
c'est pas grave la vie continue comme
poser des questions par rapport aux pas
que je répondais pas mais enfin voila l
essayer de camoufler sa part par
d'autres choses quand je renvoie de
l'énergie afin de faire des vidéos enfin
je sais pas mais c'est j'avais quand
même mal
non mais c'est que la chair en fait
ouais c'est juste caché la chose faire
semblant à ce moment-là ça c'est ca
vente à coupure sur les réseaux ou après
en vrai j'ai pas vraiment trop coupé tu
vois ce que je faisais des des
apparitions mais vraiment irrégulière
des vidéos une fois tous les deux mois
trois mois et c'est là où tu dis mais
qu'est ce que je veux vraiment apporté
de choix je me bats qu'être une
influence the way tâche at it has had
code promo tout ça les gens vont
vraiment avoir un impact sur bad touch
et d'éclairs des mentalités changent en
mode avril
comme tu disais gloria se laisse pas
facilement faire être chien le coup et
reste debout mais là ça commence à être
compliquée entre ces deux personnalités
sait plus trop comment faire et les
haters commencé à la fatigue et les
grosses il faut arrêter et à cause ma
vieille eau si j'en ai mangé du tac au
chômage est ce que c'est on estomac non
c'est le mien fais pas ta belle grosse
minute et la tête trop moche ok noir
tabou les singes est ce que tu m'as à
l'école ou soeurs je sais pas on tape
appris que le noir n'y a pas une race
inférieure parce que si je pense comme
ça ça veut dire que tu attendras à
l'époque de la ségrégation raciale la
meuf à la 2 millions de vues elle est
noire ce biais excité d'accord les deux
personnes d'accord là on va se retrouver
au tribunal
mais résolue ont donné un nom
mademoiselle loria notoriété une
identité
mais la positivité qu'elle dégage pour
masquer son mal-être a finalement ça
finit par se voir et tombe en dépression
et semoy dans plusieurs excès comme elle
l'a raconté dans une vidéo
j'avais écouté
cette période assez flou
prends ton temps sera en concurrence
avec toi armes toit de chance est temps
de faire une pause sur les réseaux elle
a besoin de souffler et quand elle
revient elle décide de marquer le coup
en magasin
fini mademoiselle gloria maintenance &
rice à gloria ces deux vrais prénoms en
fait dans la ville c'est comme pour
marquer le coup que je récupère mon
identité tu vois
et pourquoi tu prends la décision de
revenir en changeant de nom en coupant
les cheveux pour
essayer de marquer un peu une vraie bah
ouais une image enfin j'ai pas vu que
tel les attentes de britney spears est
une honte qu'il ya quand même un
changement et je voulais aussi montrer
la vie nabiye vulnérabilité
envers moi tu vois pas ce que j'étais
toujours goudou good mood et ça va aller
tu vois mes gens montrer aussi que faut
venir comme ça faut venir leur mode de
vrai et tout s'est fait il par lesquels
tu es passé qu'est ce que ça raconte sur
toi bats à une époque j'ai perdu
confiance en moi du coup là j'essaye de
re à prendre quand même à reprendre
confiance en moi et ça me robes ou sans
vraie genre tu vois je me dis bah là je
vais me battre contre l'ancienne
lauréate chômage or je vais lui montrer
que maintenant elle peut être quelqu'un
de mieux voir la meilleure version de
soi même on peut tout le temps de venir
une meilleure version temps et est ce
que tu penses que les échecs ont permis
à que tu devais une m version
d'asama ça m'a enfin sa rentrée dans mon
cas genre ça tu vois des trucs à force
d'être au bout de vagues du blog tu vois
la roma de positivité toxines longs
matches aux as tu suis ni tunnel 1 mais
du coup ça m'a je me suis ouverte à moi
même je dis à
ces principes possible de guérir de tout
ça ok
[Rires]
[Musique]
histoire de gloria c'est l'histoire de
plein de jeunes influenceurs artistes
sportifs pour qu'ils leur succès devient
un peu d'une certaine façon leur échec
et comme nous l'a démontré on peut tous
se relever de nos échecs faut jamais
abandonner pense à vous
[Musique]
ah oui avant que j'oublie n'oublie pas
ta bonne et à la chaîne et surtout mais
en commentaire en voix en dm des gens
que tu veux que j'aille interviewé
sachka pour qu'une limite président je
fais acteur je fais rappeur tout ce que
tu veux il n'y a aucune limite dans
l'échec a peut être une phrase un
mouvement politique ça ces pays
[Musique]